[Musik]
am tag der bilanz der wohnraum offensive
von bund bundesländern und den kommunen
also zweieinhalb jahre nach dem wohnungs
gipfel sprechen wir genau darüber mit
einem der für die unternehmen sprich die
mit immobilien ihr geld verdienen dem
vorsitzender der
bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft
immobilienwirtschaft deutschland die
idee
andreas ibel hallo schönen guten morgen
herr babbel sind sie zufrieden mit den
letzten zweieinhalb jahren der wohnraum
offensive teils teils aber im ergebnis
eher nicht
ich denke wir haben mehr erwartet vor
allem jetzt auch im rahmen der
baugesetzbuch novelle es gibt sicherlich
gute ansätze aber die rahmenbedingungen
haben sich grundsätzlich nicht
verbessert wir denken sogar fast oftmals
verschlechtert dann gehen wir mal in
medias res was heißt die
rahmenbedingungen haben sich eher
verschlechtert aus ihrer sicht das
bauland selber ist nicht mehr geworden
wir brauchen drink bauland wir brauchen
schnellere entscheidungen und vor allem
brauchen wir natürlich auch schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren und denn daran
hapert es ihm zunehmend wir haben nach
wie vor in den kommunen große
widerstände nicht nur auf den bauämtern
sondern natürlich auch in beiden
nachbarn in not in my backyard ist eines
der themenbereiche und da hatten wir uns
schon gehofft dass wir im rahmen der
wohnraum offensive doch einfach
schnellere verfahren haben auch die
einspruchsfristen verkürzt werden
könnten
das waren alles themen wo wir große
hoffnungen hatten und wo eigentlich
nichts passiert ist liegt das nur an der
bürokratie sie sind ja auch präsident
des sogenannten bfw des bundesverbandes
freier immobilien und
wohnungsunternehmen ihre knapp 1600
mitgliedsfirmen die sind für 50 prozent
des wohnungsneubaus in deutschland
zuständig ist das nur die bürokratie
oder warum haben die nicht genug gebaut
ich denke überall da wo wir bauen können
das heißt wo baurecht vorhanden ist wird
auch gebaut wir haben in den letzten
jahren eine verknappung von gauck ab
sie täten das heißt also es gab nicht
genug kapazitäten um wohnungen selber zu
bauen
vereinzelt haben wir das sie gesehen
aber grundsätzlich liegt es immer an der
knappheit an bauland das heißt
genehmigungsfähigen platz um ein haus zu
bauen und dort wo eine genehmigung
vorliegt wird in der regel auch bebaut
sei denn es gibt irgendwelchen
widerstand vor ort den man so nicht
erwartet hat gibt es da nicht vielleicht
auch gute gründe wenn gemeinde wenn
kommunen wenn städte eben gewisses land
nicht freigeben oder im zweifel auch gar
kein land mehr zur verfügung ist ich
mein wenn man durch deutsche großstädte
fährt dann sieht man ja da gibt es so
was wie baulücken gibt es ja häufig
schon gar nicht mehr
naja man muss glaube ich das thema
bauland ein bisschen weiter denken
jeder hat immer wenn man wenn wir über
baulandausweisung die grüne wiese die
ökologische waldgebiet vor augen dass
vernichtet wird das ist hier nicht der
fall sondern wir wenn wir heute über
bauland reden reden wir über
brachflächen das heißt ob es nun die
zwei großen flughäfen in berlin sind die
einfach geteerte dort liegen bleiben
zumindest die landebahnen und weiter
nicht genutzt werden das sind alles
potenzielle bauflächen so kann man sich
das vorstellen und wenn dort neues
baurecht geschaffen wird dann kann man
dort auch die wohnungen bauen die
bezahlbar sind und umso mehr bauland
ausgewiesen wird desto günstiger wird es
letztendlich weil wir haben im moment
ist mit einer verknappung zu tun wir
haben die verknappung ja nicht überall
denn es gibt auch viele viele gemeinden
die genug wohnraum anzubieten haben das
vornehmlich in den kernen der kleinen
städte und auch darüber müssen wir
nachdenken bauland ist genug waren nur
nicht an der richtigen stelle und das
ist glaube ich große diskussionen die
große gesellschaftspolitische aufgabe
die wir vor uns haben und die andere
gesellschaftspolitische sind die mieten
diese wohnung offensive ging ja auch um
bezahlbare mieten dass es offenbar
gescheitert die sind in fast allen
großstädten deutschlands in den letzten
jahren durch die decke gegangen auch in
mittelgroßen städten ihre mitglieder im
bfw verwalten auch über drei millionen
wohnungen mehr als 14 prozent aller
vermieteten wohnungen in deutschland
ich verstehe dass die natürlich geld
verdienen wollen verstehen sie auch das
mieten noch bezahlbar bleiben müssen und
für viele zum beispiel familien oder
eben nicht so überragend verdienende das
nicht mehr möglich ist
ja auf jeden fall ein bezahlbares wohnen
ist das thema unserer zeit und da die
einkommen derzeit auf jeden fall nicht
steigen können die mieten eigentlich
auch nicht weiter steigen das tut sie
alles um das tun sie haben und wir
müssen uns ja sie tun es aber ich denke
wir ist jetzt an einem die wir sind
jetzt an einem punkt gekommen wo die
mieten nicht weiter steigen und sie
steigen auch nicht überall sondern sie
steigen in ballungszentren die die
menschen haben ihre lebensform ihre
lebensort in den letzten jahren sehr
stark verändert und jetzt auf einmal
wollten wollten alle wollten auf einmal
in berlin leben und alle in die
großstädte gehen in den kleinen städten
hat sich ist das nicht ist er mir nicht
mitgekommen und wir haben damit ist
nicht geschafft dort genügend
bezahlbaren wohnraum zur verfügung zu
stellen
ich denke die bundesregierung hat da
richtig reagiert sie hat nämlich die
öffentliche förderung für
sozialwohnungen erhöht sich ja das
wohngeld erhöht ich glaube da sind
entscheidende schritte gemacht worden
und ich glaube auch dass im moment ein
ende dieses mietpreisanstieg gesehen
haben wir haben jetzt auch in den
letzten halben jahr auch die ersten
rückgänge wieder gesehen
aber es bleibt abzuwarten wie sie die
entwicklung weitergeht nach corona wenn
ich sie richtig verstehe herr ebel dann
sehen sie das was der deutsche
mieterbund und mehrere große
gewerkschaften fordern wenn ich ein
moratorium sechs jahre lang auf
mieterhöhungen zu verzichten dann sehen
sie das eigentlich positiv und würden
sagen ja dass wir eine option
nein das sehen wir nicht positiv weil
wir glauben mit diesem moratorium trifft
es auf jeden fall die falschen wir haben
gerade in berliner mieten deckel gesehen
dass es ein dazu führt dass eben nicht
mehr genug wohnraum auf den markt kommt
eine eine eine solche deckelung und und
ganz starken eingriff in den mietmarkt
führt eigentlich dazu dass erstens nicht
mehr saniert wird wir müssen dringend
die wohnungsbestände klimaneutralen
sanieren und zweitens führt es eben dazu
dass diejenigen die in eine stadt neu
kommen die werden benachteiligt und
diejenigen die in einer stadt sitzen die
dort wohnen die
geschützt und ziehen auch nicht mehr um
wenn sie es könnten
das führt zu ganz erheblichen
verwerfungen am mietmarkt und das kann
man am beispiel berlin sehr gut sehen
der berliner mit markt ist leer gefegt
seit es den mieten deckel gibt über
keiner mehr umziehen und das führt zu
einem ganz letzten problem mich dass
gerade im sozialen wohnungsbau sei für
menschen die die auf billige mieten ja
angewiesen sind offenbar nicht genug da
sind der präsident des deutschen
mieterbundes lukas siebenkotten der
kritisiert dass dieser soziale
wohnungsbau wirklich eben viel zu kurz
käme daran haben ihre unternehmer im
zweifel auch kein interesse
sozialwohnungen zu bauen oder doch doch
also zumindest wir waren ja nicht nur 50
prozent aller mietwohnungen in
deutschland neu sondern auch 50 prozent
der sozialwohnungen sind ja von privaten
investoren gebaut worden und zumindest
werden auch in diese investiert und
natürlich haben wir auch ein interesse
dass dieses dieser bereich weiter
ausgebaut wird ich denke dafür müssen
nur die förder und rahmenbedingungen
stimmen und das ist eine sehr teure
sache man muss sich sehr genau überlegen
zum beispiel brauchen wir diese
sozialwohnung für jeden ist er ist ist
die die verteilung der sozialwohnung
überhaupt gerecht 1 ist aber auch ganz
klar ist fallen derzeit mehr
sozialwohnungen aus der bindung raus als
neu erstellt werden und darüber müssen
wir noch mal miteinander nachdenken kann
man vielleicht mal sozial den
sozialwohnungsbau von der mehrwertsteuer
befreit ist das ist ein thema also ich
denke man muss hier etwas kreativer
rangehen ein weiter so geht auf jeden
fall nicht andreas ibel der vorsitzende
der bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft
immobilienwirtschaft deutschland bei
idee und selbst auch projektierer vielen
dank herr ebel hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch
dank abt power schönen tag